ظهر الممثل براد كارتر في مسلسلات مثل ترو
ديتكتيف وسي اس ايي لكن دوره الاخير قد
يكون
مفاجئا كان كارتر نجم هذا الفيديو لعب
الجيتار خلال عمليه التحفيز الدماغي
العميق ويقول كارتر انه لم يتوقع لاحد
رؤيته لكنه انتشر بسرعه وحاز على العديد
من المشاهدات سبب دخوله لغرفه العمليات هي
حاله من الرجفه الاساسيه فعندما يحاول لعب
الجيتار بسرعه ابطا ي عليه الامر وامضى
كارتر سنوات بتشخيص خاطئه بينما تزداد
حالته سوءا مرض لايم وباركنسون وقد اثرت
الرجفه في قدره كارتر على العمل الاستسلام
لم يكن خيارا لكارتر فقد اختار الخضوع
لعمليه التحفيز الدماغي العميق بدوران
تيار كهربائي في دماغه في محاوله للسيطره
على تلك الرجفه يقول كارتر انه كان خائفا
خلال العمليه الا انه لم يرد عيش بقيه
حياته مع هذا المرض وبعد خضوعه للعمليه ت
حالته من جديد الا انه اراد الخضوع
للعمليه مره اخرى رغم ضاله فرص شفائه منها
وبعد العمليه الثانيه لم يشفى كارتر بشكل
تام لكن الرشفه اصبحت اخف بكثير مما كانت
عليه لكن مثابره كارتر وقوته قاده الى هنا
البوم جديد
له